marry a poll just weeks ago was a Scenic
Port City now mercilessly bombarded cut
off from the rest of Ukraine and would
likely be in Russian hands today but for
the fearlessness of the controversial
azov Battalion one Russian President
Vladimir Putin vowed to denotify and
root out fascists in Ukraine his prime
propaganda symbol was the reputation of
the azov regiment he wants to
demonstrate on Russian television
captured fighters of uh you know Azo
Battalion years ago as of began as a
volunteer force and was populated with
right wing and racist elements not
trusted by many ukrainians or the west
but it defended Mario poll in 2014 and
was crucial in training ukrainians to
prepare for war in 2022 it was drawn
images from azov that showed the world
what was happening in Maria Paul and by
all accounts azov has proved to be a
fierce resistance to Russian forces
Ukrainian writer Anton shakopsov as of
today is a highly professional Special
Operations Detachment to stress not a
political organization not a militia not
a far-right battalion Russians are
focused now on eastern Ukraine and
control much of the region but in
Marriott Hall the azov Battalion is
still defending and denying Russia
complete control from the East to Crimea
and the Russians very obviously are
trying to establish a land bridge
between occupied Crimea and the donbass
and the as of Battalion are the main
defenders in mariopo who are preventing
this Russian Victory now part of the
Ukraine National Guard but never as well
equipped as the Ukrainian military the
isolated azov Battalion must now
confront a reinforced Russian military
focused on the East it's astonishing how
they've managed to hold out in Mario but
they have not been able to be resupplied
so it's a very heroic resistance which
might not last very much longer
azov may be outgunned in the end but in
the war to save Ukraine it has won over
Skeptics who now see them as Valiant
Patriots Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto